At the end of the previous video we ended at the following iteration
with the following paths forward.
We started with a vague question.
How popular were the different brands of candy?
And we considered the two possible metrics, interselection time and
total number of selections for quantifying this question.
We ended up choosing as an initial guess interselection time.
Now that we have a metric interselection time that we
feel captures what we're interested in, we must use it
to cast the above question as a problem of a statistical inference.
So there are many options for doing so.
One is point estimation, in which we explicitly try to create a estimator for
our quantity interselection time.
Another is confidence sets, in which we try to create an interval,
which traps the true value of inter selection time with some confidence level.
Classification, in which we choose various descriptive classes which may
not be ordered.
And try to classify interselection time into one of those classes.
So for example in contrast with point estimation in which we explicitly try to
come up with an estimator for the actual value of interselection time.
In classification we may choose just broad categories like short or
long and try to match the actual quantity to one of those classes.
Hypothesis testing in which we for example, might try to determine if
two different collections of inter selection time values came from two different
probability distributions and how much confidence we have in that being true.
Or lastly, parameter estimation in which we try to do things like.
Find the parameter of a Poisson distribution,
or find the bandwidth value on a kernel density estimation.
Which we'll talk a lot more about, in a later lesson.
Depending on the outcome of later phases, we may return to the question phase,
to recast the same problem as a different statistical inference problem.
For example, we may find the regression estimator we create has
a very high variance, thus poor performance but
can be recast as a classifier with a very high accuracy.
Let's state this problem more formally.
Our goal is to build a regression estimator, r.
R will tell us its estimate for an interselection time for
a candy, c, at any given turn.
Our data points are just the candy selections and
the order in which they were selected.
With the inter-selection time written beside them.
In other words, given the list of candy selections, and
the number of turns since each candy had last been chosen.
We are going to build an estimator, R, that will tell us at a given turn for
a given candy how long it has been since it was last selected.
Let's consider our next possible paths for analysis.
At this stage really our only options are to proceed with
the regression estimator.
Which means identifying features or revisiting an earlier stop.
In the next video we'll proceed with feature selection.